- From time to time.
I like to get out of the studio
to hang out with our guests,
feel the sunshine and fresh air.
We call these segments 'drive interviews'.
(upbeat music)
♪ Drive interview ♪
(applause)
All right.
You'll never guess who showed up
and in what car
at the outdoor theater the other day.
Take a look.
(triumphant music)
(upbeat techno music)
- Hey you!
- What's up?
(dramatic upbeat music)
- [Kelly] I love your car.
- [David] I love your car.
(dramatic upbeat music)
- You win. You brought K.I.T.T.
(laughing)
This is amazing.
(upbeat music)
One of my first cars that I
ever got, I named K.I.T.T.
It was a Cadillac XLR.
It was black.
It was like a true sports car
and I was like, his name shall be K.I.T.T.
(upbeat music)
- K.I.T.T.'s amazing.
You know, the most amazing
thing about K.I.T.T.
is that today, K.I.T.T. is still relevant.
Maybe after 36, 40 years later,
everything is exactly what we came up with
back in the day.
It's weird.
The cars talk.
The cars drive themselves.
They park.
- [Kelly] Yeah. That's amazing!
(upbeat music)
- Speaking of Knight Rider, though,
there were a lot of, like, stunts.
Did you do any of the stunts?
- Yeah. Y'all. Well I did.
I got really good at driving
because I wanted to,
and the reverse 180 is,
I could teach you that
in about five minutes.
We had no CGI
and we did everything by
the seam of our pants.
And the best part about it
(laughing)
was they would have 40 guys out there
paid not to kill me.
And they would say "Action, Knight Rider!"
and I just go, 'Woo Hoo!'
and I just do a WD-40 and spray the wheels
and spin out, spin through it, go through.
And they were all--.
- You got paid for that!
- Can you believe it?
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- It's incredible.
(light upbeat music)
- Would you ever do a reboot?
- There is a reboot in the making,
so we'll see what happens.
- Yeah.
(light techno music)
- Actually, I heard,
there was a Hoff auction?
- Yeah. We had an auction.
- Where was the Hoff auction?
- You know, I went to the Hoff auction.
It was like going to my funeral.
It was like going to a different time,
you know, it's best just
to get rid of this stuff,
sell it, give the money to charity,
which I gave a lot of money to
the Global Mobility Company,
which makes children walk.
It creates wheelchairs for them.
I've still got like four
or five auctions left.
(light upbeat music)
- I heard that one of your
most prized possessions,
involves SpongeBob?
- Yeah. One of my prize
possessions in my house
is a 13 and a half foot,
750 pound version of David Hasselhoff.
- [Kelly] What?
- Going like.
(camera shutters)
- I feel like you just put it
right as you enter your home.
(laughing)
- Right as people walk in.
- I was thinking about
having it as a mailbox.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] That would be amazing.
(light techno music)
You have a heavy metal album coming out?
- I did a heavy metal song, you know,
called 'Through the Night'.
- That's so cool.
- You do what's in front of you.
I just go with the flow Kelly.
I mean, the phone didn't
ring for 10 years,
now the phone's ringing.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
That's awesome.
(upbeat techno music)
I just wanted to tell you
I love your show and
my kids love your show
and everybody loves it
because you're honest,
because you tell the truth
and because you're fun, you know?
- Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm too lazy to be a
liar or anything else.
(laughing)
I just do me.
And if you like it, cool.
If you don't, that's cool.
- [David] Yeah.
- Yeah.
Well, thank you for doing the show.
- You're welcome honey.
God bless. Take care.
- All right later, man.
- [David] All right.
(upbeat techno music)
- [Kelly] Later!
(applause)
- All right.
So is it true that you have
a new project in Germany?
- I do.
I have a show, a series,
and it's about my time
behind the Berlin wall
and it's kind of like fact or fiction
and we start shooting in August
and it's going to be mostly in English,
but a little bit of German
and it's going to be really exciting.
- Oh my God.
It sounds amazing.
The story's incredible, just in real life.
So I can't imagine it being on film.